to make gingerbread house kits the
factory starts with baking soda a
leavening ingredient a worker adds a
scoop of salt to the baking soda and
measures these ingredients by weight he
transfers the baking soda and salt to an
enormous mixer he measures the spices
cinnamon ginger nutmeg and allspice he
closes the mixer and the system pipes in
water molasses and sugar at the top of
the mixer he tosses in a big block of
vegetable shortening
the mixer creams all the ingredients and
blends in the flour producing a
putty-like dough
a spiraling mechanism now helps move the
dough onto a conveyor a roller flattens
the chunks so they won't fall off during
the steep climb at the top the conveyor
levels off and delivers the chunks of
dough to a machine known as a sheeter
because it rolls the pieces into a
seemingly endless sheet a large cookie
cutter swoops down propelled by
compressed air it punches out various
shapes producing gingerbread cookies
that will fit together to form a house
the cookie cutouts land on moving rubber
coated wires separators between the
wires knock off the excess gingerbread
dough to be captured and mixed into the
next batch
the cookies then leave the wire
conveyors and a mesh one takes them up
to a baking sheet belt the baking sheet
belt travels slowly through a long
convection oven exiting the oven the
baked gingerbread shapes transfer to a
spiral conveyor and after a 30 minute
ride the dough has cooled and firmed up
workers stack the pieces for one
gingerbread house onto a piece of
cardboard and they're ready to be
packaged with the rest of the kit
elsewhere in the factory they blend
together the icing ingredients for the
kits with the icing ready plastic
packaging moves towards hot jaws that
seal the bottoms a robot grabs a package
and opens the top and a fill nozzle
pumps the icing into it
another robot applies an applicator tip
and heat seals the plastic around it a
worker retrieves them and places them in
a box for transfer to the kit assembly
station
once packaged in a kit these gingerbread
houses are ready for quick builds